[Music]
my name is Carmen and I'm on the Android
performance team and today I'm going to
show you some examples of analyzing
performance using systrace before I do I
want to remind you that your app is not
an island it's running on top of several
layers you know the phone hardware the
android framework libraries that you're
incorporating a/b tests so you might
think you know what your code is doing
but the reality might actually surprise
you and this is where systrace comes in
so systrace is a tool that lets you
collect precise timing information about
what's going on on your device and then
visualize it it records down to the
individual CPU time slice on the Android
performance team it's the most important
tool we have for debugging performance
issues Tim Murray and I have given some
talks about how to use systrace in the
past and if you want to know more about
that google for his i/o talk but today
I'm going to focus on showing you what
kind of issues you can find in your app
when you use systrace so I took traces
of three apps that I don't work on but I
could still quickly find potential
improvements to their startup time so
let's jump in with the first app when I
look at the trace 3 different activity
starts jumped out at me right away there
are a lot of reasons to use trampoline
activities I see them a lot when
developers are trying to show a splash
screen or do a permissions check
something like that but they definitely
impact your launch time and depending on
what you're trying to do there might be
a better way so if you're trying to make
a splash screen you could set up a
special launch theme or for permissions
you could refactor your code so that you
only open the separate activity if you
need to I don't know why this app has
these activities and maybe they are
critical but if they don't that's a 160
millisecond in the same app I also
browse through the names of the views
being inflated by this app based on the
name of this highlighted view in the
second row it looks like it's a drawer
view your views are always a bit of a
conundrum because they often have a lot
of child views and they take a long time
to inflate but sometimes we need them
immediately for UX reasons
if this app can pull this inflate out of
the critical path of startup they could
save 42 more milliseconds so this second
app is following the pattern for app
startups that I would expect in the top
there's no extra activities or services
being started I dug in a little more
clicked on the views that were being
inflated and the names of the widgets
that I could see matched up with what
was visible when the app started so far
so good but then I saw this gap in
activity inside bind application that
takes up 30 milliseconds when I click on
that trace point I'll see that it's
monitor contention and I get more
information so monitor contention is
another way of saying lot contention
where the owner of the lock is the
thread pool 3 thread 1 so that's in the
top row and so I scrolled down and I did
in fact see activity in pool 3 thread 1
during this time and then it's given me
a pointer to the stack so I wasn't
familiar with realms so I looked it up
and it's like a mobile database library
like sequel so the function names kind
of make sense here and this one may or
may not be something that you can fix as
an app developer because you might need
to coordinate with the realm library but
if you had a monitor contention between
two threads that you wrote in your say
map it would look the same
either way this is another potential 30
millisecond opportunity for this app
where they could get a start up
improvement by resolving the slot
contention in this app there are two
activities being started
but there's another potential
improvement here too you see that I
included the thread name over on the
left on the screenshot this is the UI
thread so if we scroll down and see
what's going on on the other threads in
this app we can see these background
threads running a CPU 0 CPU one CPU 2
and it's awesome that the app developers
made background threads to do some of
their work but there's a potential
performance issue here that jumps out at
me as well which is that these
background threads are doing a lot of
blocking i/o so that's the orange
sections in the CPU activity bars on the
trace they're kind of hard to see so you
can see there's some i/o happening on
all three of these threads now it turns
out that on a lot of devices we have to
be concerned about i/o contention
there's not necessarily more than one IO
channel to use to access the disk at
once so these background threads may
actually be slowing down the i/o
requests from the UI thread so that
section is highlighted down below we
scroll up we see the busy for 10
milliseconds overlaps with these
activity starts by viewing the thread
time slices in aggregate we can see that
in this section we spend a hundred and
seven milliseconds in blocking i/o we
could potentially shorten this amount of
time significantly if we move that
background activity to overlap with
something else
all I needed to do to collect these
traces was to clone the catapult get
repo and run this trace command you can
just open the output HTML file in your
browser and see everything that I showed
you today and this barely scratches the
surface of what you can do with systrace
I was able to identify these potential
opportunities in apps I don't work on
using only the trace points provided by
the system when you look at a trace of
your own app with the expertise you
already have it's gonna make a hundred
times more sense to you and you can even
add your own trace points inside your
app codes so you can see the context of
what's running in your app from within
the trace thank you
[Music]